each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
20 million pounds worth of projects at
the moment mostly mid collaboration with
with industry and our main headline is
that we work on scalable information
management and within that this four
areas there versus scalable systems
virtual organizations and systems
biology and we do quite a variety of
working these areas in the scalability
area we do a lot of work on modeling
systems so we've got some people who can
do all the hard master to model grid
systems dynamic deployment of jobs and
systems where you essentially question
like where do you deploy them what
resources you give to them India basis
we do the the gamut really parallel
systems distributed systems particularly
other resources that we've done on the
acquire so I started off building custom
parallel dirt their systems in a in a
company and what you do there is you you
buy a box and you've done only deploy
the bits of the query across the notably
in the box here what we're doing is
we're dynamically grabbing nodes that
are free made available by grid
middleware so that may be anywhere in
the world and using those in order to do
queries virtual organizations so we we
work with a group of small chemical
companies what they want to do is to
collaborate and they feel that the
current ways of doing it with faxes and
phone calls and so on don't scale so
they want an automated system for that
and that requires us to think about well
how do you deal with issues such as the
workflow to describe the overall process
of the collaboration securely so you're
very clear about who's allowed to see
and do what particular with each other's
information and audit so recording
exactly who did what when compared to
what they were supposed to do and if all
fails you've got some sort of a record
you can give to some lawyers to go and
sort it out and the main application
driver that we have for all of this is
systems biology so the buzzword for this
changes over the years but systems
biology is the current one and what this
means is is really about instead of just
concentrate on some small aspect of
biology like some aspect of genetics
what you're looking at and is how
genetics relates the function relates to
how organs behave and how all all whole
organisms behaved so it's gone right up
through the the different layers
combining models and they stay together
so the specific talk I was going to give
today was on the work we've been doing
on databases in these sorts of
applications and to describe the
motivation for this I wanted to want it
to give you what I really like which is
BALCA standard scientific models so Jeff
Balkans a sociologist a historian of
science and he he analyzes the way in
which science works in reality and he
says that there's three stages in the
way in which scientists work so first of
all they do experiments and clegg data
then they publish papers on the on the
date I having analyzed it and then the
third stage is that they gradually lose
the original dare so if you if you try a
lots of things in science you'll find
that people keep their around now it is
on the sea drives of their laptop and
the right the papers having analyzed it
and then when the disk crash is that's
the end of the day on which the science
was best and this causes several
problems it means that different
scientists can't analyze the same day
and get different value from it perhaps
try different analyses of it it also
means we don't get reproducibility so
reproducibility is supposed to be a big
thing in science but unless you've got
the original data then you can't
reproduce the experiment so a lot of
what e science has been about over the
last few years has been about trying to
understand how we address these this
problem and so going back to Tony here
now you're now the VP for technical
computing at Microsoft in the UK science
program he pushed a lot of the work in
this direction so traditionally grid
computing has been about connecting
supercomputers together scheduling jobs
on big machines Tony felt with a lot of
us that really it was to do with
information management that was the key
thing that scientists needed so there's
been a lot of work in this area in the
UK and just to reinforce this point I
had looked at some lab books so done now
we're talking about electronic
books earlier this is a lab book from
1892 from Wisconsin and to soil
scientists and you can see how he
described the experiment he was doing
and then he gave some information about
the results of the experiment down here
and here's a more modern one so you may
not be able to see this but I really
like this one to illustrate the point so
this is this is from 1987 it's dated at
the at the top and you can see that so
this is this is useful so that what this
is is the the metadata that describes
the base data so it's a set of
experiments and these were the
parameters that we used on each of these
experiments and then it says basically
if you want to find the data then you
just look in these files here and here's
a is printed out this put the sciences
printed out the the set of files and
tick them so you can see which ones are
actually related to the to the dirt here
so so we can have a we could have a
discussion about what we thinks the
probability that we could go and look at
this this theater now and I feel it
would be it's probably zero I imagine
this this pill machines long deceased
and these files are no longer available
so all we got left is the metadata and
we've lost their their order itself and
this is a real ongoing problem in
science so he signs has been trying to
change this so trying to move towards
this model that you collect the data and
you publish the date as well as the
purpose and there's been lots of work in
various places so for example Jim Gray
at Microsoft's done some really
pioneering work in this area with
colleagues in the area of astronomy so
there's the sky server which collects
lots of astronomical data and makes it
available to anybody any astronomer who
wants to to use it so it's moving
astronomy from being about astronomers
looking through telescopes at it parts
of the sky and analyzing that towards
astronomers sending sequel queries
towards towards the sky survey database
and extract any information from and in
the UK we've had as I said there's been
a big push in this area of information
management for e science and so for
example as a project oxidizer we are
involved in which is about making it
easy to take databases and
publish them so that others other
applications can use them and the way
the way I look at it was what we're
trying to do is to set up an ecosystem
so so if you look at the web services
will then I also like to use Amazon is a
good example because what they did they
decided to make their system available
through web services and twenty five
percent of their revenue now comes from
through the web services rather than
from the normal web pages that we tend
to use and one of the reasons for this
is that there's this ecosystem of
services which build on the amazon
services so this one's for example where
you can go into a bookstore with it with
a camera phone and take a photograph of
an ISBN number and immediately will tell
you on your on your phone how much that
would cost amazon there's a little
button you can you can click if you want
to buy from amazon if it seems cheap
will you prepared to wear so so so
amazon made this available and then
clever people produce other services
have build on those and then there's
other services that build on those and
so on so we want this healthy ecosystem
with the date or at the bottom of it and
so this is this is the idea and this is
starting to to happen now people are
writing these services and publishing
them one of the good things about using
databases for this is that it's really
important to promote locality so if
you've got large databases the sky
service up to about 4 terabytes at the
long I think it's supposed to be going
up to seven or eight terabytes so what
you need to do is to push as much of the
computation towards the dirt as possible
not to move the the data towards the
computation and databases are good at
this because you can send queries which
effectively move the computation the day
you can group queries together so we do
that in oxid I Jim Gray is very keen on
stored procedures so it produces higher
level functions useful things and
provides them very close to the database
so I'll make up an example an astronomy
letter you're interested in white dwarfs
there's some sort of analysis you do to
find white dwarf in particular over the
sky rather than transfer lots of data
out of the database and locally look for
dwarves if there's some standard way to
do this sort of analysis then you could
create that as a stored procedure in the
dirt verse and anybody could use that
the computation goes on in the database
server without the debt having to be
moved remotely and Jim sky server also
has this idea that the results of
queries are typically stored back in the
database itself so you as a user when
you register with the sky server you get
your own little bit about a little part
of the sky server and your the results
of your queries go in there so quite
often that's very useful you can do
things like you can run one analysis
store the results run another one with
different parameters saw the results and
then you can compare the two again using
queries and all this kid keeps the data
together but there are limits to this so
this is the this is a problem we've hit
and then it's the what the first part of
this talk is going to be about so what
you find is that so the reason for the
thickness of these arrows was that what
you finds if you make a database service
available then scientists are clever
people and they keep coming up with new
ideas so you can't predict in advance
what they want to do with the dirt so
they're going to cycle into work
nonetheless if only I could write an
analysis service which did this you know
the Nobel Prize starts to loom up in
front of their eyes so what you need to
be able to do as I say is to have this
ecosystem where they can write a write a
service which uses the the best there
does something interesting with but
they're they're going to deploy that
service locally away from the database
they don't own the database itself they
can't go and install software on it and
so what you get is quite often a
consumer sent to request to this
analysis service that the scientists
written it sends us request the day of
their service members of query and back
comes an awful lot of dirt after this
analysis service which then rattles
around producing a result and here's an
example of some results from a
bioinformatics service where you can see
that this is the this is a log scale the
tuples requested by the analysis service
as it goes up you get this tremendous
increase in total processing time and
for this service we analyzed it and that
cost was because of the cost of moving
the data from the database service over
very
networks to this analysis service where
it could be then the i'll be bound for
matix algorithm could it was a signal
similarity algorithm which could then
perform on the day so yes you all these
requests when they start consuming all
the resources on these day later so the
sky server what it does is it has 2 q's
it has a high priority queue which is
basically interactive in a lower
priority queue it isn't and if the query
gets beyond a certain point in terms of
resources use then it gets pushed back
from the from the high priority queue to
the low priority kuna gets done when
resources are available so you try to
allow most of your users to see very
good very good response time from the
system but still allow them to run very
long Queen sits then get scheduled in
the background when times available but
there are other I guess there are other
approaches you could use you could work
out who the user was and give them some
sort of a quota most databases will will
allow you to do that but as i say that i
think if i remember rightly that's what
the sky servitors in this case or you
buy a bigger debt based machine i guess
is what others that's it so
yeah in so in grid computing this
possibly a solution to this so so grid
computers you notice how to as had a
meteoric rise in the past four or five
years and most of the work is about
remote job scheduling so instead of just
creating an executable giving some
parameters and running it on your
desktop or your laptop you give it to
some Middle where it goes and finds a
free machine somewhere might be on your
organization's network perhaps on the pc
on the desktop somebody was on holiday
or in a meeting and it runs there and
the results come back and there's this
middleware like Condor and Globus and so
on which which allow you to do this
fairly straightforwardly so so this is
in order to do this you as I say you
have to create these jobs and we thought
well why do we have jobs as well as
services we thought this was confusing
so people are writing these services to
do in our seat and so on but but what
they then find is that well this service
requires more computational power than
the Machine I've installed it on has
possibly because it's popular and has
lots of users so then we have to create
these jobs and schedule the jobs so we
decided to explore an alternative which
was just to have services so we threw
out the idea of jobs and just
concentrate on services so these are
these are web services that way that
we're dealing with and we explored an
infrastructure which we call dinosaur
which deals with this so it's a as I say
service only approach the grid computing
another way to look at it is it's an
infrastructure for dynamically deploying
web services on demand where they're
needed so this is a sort of web services
001 so you've got consumer it sends a
message sort message to the web service
and memo not get a response back to it
eventually so that's that's the stander
in which web services work what we've
done is to think about splitting up the
the right hand side the web service in
the two components which interact
through a standard interface so we have
this web service provider and as far as
a consumers concern it can't tell the
difference it doesn't know that
clever going on the consumer just sends
a request to the web service provider so
the web service providers exposing the
service endpoint when the sort message
arrives there then the web service right
has to find somewhere for that sort
message to be processed so there are
these host providers which have
processing power to process the messages
and the resources for services to be
deployed on and the the trick in what we
what we've done the bit that's kept us
interested for the last few years is
that we can dynamically deploy services
as required so when the website variety
decides that this is the host provider
which should process the message it
doesn't have to be the case that the
services already deployed on that host
provider so we can deploy the service on
demand as required so I've got a couple
of animations of this I've been
traveling a lot on airplanes and long
flight so I've managed to master
powerpoint animation so you can see the
year the sort message flying from the
consumer to the web service provider
when it gets there the web service
provider this looks at the short message
and these words intended so it's
intended for s2 service to which is
actually deployed on here and on here in
this horse provider and so the web
service provider then passes the message
to the host provider and it can select
from one of those two installations
passes the message to it where it's
processed and then the results are
returned to the consumer so that's
that's very straightforward it faculty
they'll hear the web service provides
just acting as a intermediary just
passing the message on to an instance of
the service word gets more interesting
is where the service isn't already
deployed so this is a request for s4
service for the consumer as this sort
message that it sends again to the web
service provider the web service
provider passes on to the horse provider
and at this point the services and
deployed s4 isn't on any of the nodes of
the host provider so what we do is the
web server ID
for every service that it offers to
consumers it has a service repository
faculty the library of services in a
deployable form and so the host provider
can then send a request to the web
service provider for that particular
service and the service then gets sent
back to the horse provider which can
install it on the node of its choice or
a set of nodes of its choice and the
message can then be folded to it
processed and the result returned so one
of the advantage of this we feel is the
unlike job scheduling so with job
shutting once the jobs being executed
that's it you you return the results but
you lose all of the cord in the day that
was sent it you can't reuse it because
what we're doing is deploying services
we once the service is deployed it can
remain in place and can be there to
process subsequent messages so the cost
of deploying the service is spread of
the cost of all of the messages it
processes it processes once it has been
deployed so we think this gives a
performance advantage over of a job
scheduling it becomes particularly
important where the cost of deployment
is high so when we first did this we
used to use Java services and so what we
were moving were war file so these these
descriptions of services which you drop
into a directory and access tom cat and
then the service becomes available so
that's what was being moved from the web
service ride to the node we've since
done some work with virtual pc and
virtual server so we have a we have a an
image of the of the service and all of
its environment in a frozen virtual
machine and this is what's stored in the
repository here and this is what's moved
now that that's a I see that has been
the way of the future because you can
set up a complete computational
environment so one of the real problems
with jobs is that you often code needs a
very specific environment in which to
ruin you need a particular version of
the operating system you need particular
see libraries you need particular
software to to be on the nodes and this
is a real
for many attempts to produce generic
generic grid software you tend to allow
the idea of grids that you have a very
heterogeneous mix and machines in which
you deploy these jobs in practice people
often have to really screw down the
implement the environment on each note
so it's very very homogenous each node
has to move forward instead because you
can't afford for the sea libraries to go
out the step otherwise computations fail
but if you're if you're moving a virtual
machine than all that environments are
actually in there and you don't need to
worry too much about what the what the
note itself provides as long as it
supports that virtual machine but these
virtual machines can be very big so with
Java what with these Java war files we
were moving you know a small number of
Meg's at the most with these virtual
machines you can moving the order of
gigs because you've got the you got the
operating system and the memory that
it's deployed in the service and the
context within it so the cost of moving
it and deploying it as much as much
higher so so really when you do this we
feel that you want to get the benefit
rather than just a single message
message being process you want it to
remain that and process multiple
messages so so we so this is what we we
feel the potential advantages of this
approach so it's simple we just have
services now people right services they
put them in these repositories these
libraries and they're dynamically
deployed is required efficiency as I
said because we the deployed service can
process many messages one thing that
that's also proved helpful is that
another barrier to the use of services
and in sign systems is that the pain of
installing a service on a machine by
hand so people produce services and
abuse and whether for four or five pages
of installation script which have to do
manually to install the service now
effectively by having a standard
repository for services and the standard
way to install them you move that
complexity to the producer of the
service you force them to package it in
a particular way and the cost of the use
of that service is effectively zero so
so we see this has been a way of
reducing the barrier of entry to using
men
services and because we have a
separation now of two things about this
horse provides to provide the resources
got this web service providers who
provide the services themselves then we
think you get an interesting set of new
e-science need business models which
will now a look at some of them so this
is a classic example which comes up in
in research as well as in we think in
business so this is this is a group
called bio Corp here but it could be a
research group and they're really good
at writing services biological services
but they don't have any expertise are
interested in hosting those services so
what they can do is they can offer these
services here and get into a business
relationship with a hosting company and
as the messages come in for these
services they can try to take a micro
payment they can check that there these
are bonafide II customers who are
sending these messages and if they are
they can pass them on of a post provider
and as before if necessary the service
will be dynamically deployed as required
one of the other things that tourney hit
did when he was in the UK was he set up
a national grid service which was a four
clusters each with a 128 nodes the
people around the UK could use for signs
so they could schedule jobs on them and
it looks like it looks like this at the
moment if you want to deploy services on
there then you have to ask nicely and
they'll let you or give you a node and
then you can go in and manually deploy
the service and then use it but by
putting a host provider on here on this
national grid what this allows for
example would be a researcher who
doesn't have any great local
computational resources but has lots of
bright ideas about services to write the
service to deploy it to put it in a
service repository at their own
institution here and then this web
service repository can pass on any
messages sent to that service to the
National Grid service and the services
are then installed as required on demand
on the National Grid service and one of
the things you can do because you've got
these services in deplorable form then
you
can use this to scale up so we've got
some mathematical models which say for
example X a service over here become
becomes very popular so rather than just
have a single insulation over here over
time you could deploy the same service
on multiple nodes and perhaps when it
became unfashionable not so popular
again it would contract back to a
smaller even zero nodes on the national
grid service what makes virtual machine
technology really useful in this context
is that once you push the service over
in the node you provide really strong
isolation between that node and the
virtual machine so if the service does
some bad things or you know whether or
not is full content or not you can still
throw it away and you still haven't you
still haven't no that's capable of you
know hosting other services whereas if
you were just wanting it work natively
on that note it can do all sorts of
things would make it very very hard
probably services to provide their
capabilities on there now yeah so to
completely agree I think that's really
important there's also the other
direction as well some people like that
like the idea that perhaps is less
likely that the owner of the node can
poke in and find out what their what
they're doing pharmaceutical companies
tend to worry about that a lot in our
experience so yeah so so that's a good
point and so at the moment for services
that have these what they call
quarantine nodes and when you first
deploy service manually it has to go on
one of these nodes and they monitor it
very closely to make sure it's not doing
any damage to the to the node itself and
only then when they're comfortable do
they spread it out across the other set
of nodes now as you said using virtual
machines hopefully it gets rid of that
yeah if you're not using virtual
machines then you can still do this by
policy so you have it that the first
time they the service was deployed it
gets deployed in one of these nodes and
then when somebody's happy in the put a
tick in a box it can be deployed
dynamically on the other nodes as well
and the other
advantage of this that we started to
work on now is that because you've got a
well-defined interface between the web
service providers offering the service
and the post providers are providing the
compute power to deploy and process
messages you can put a broker a
third-party broker in between so this
can make a dynamic choice of host
provider based on criteria so price
might be one in a commercial environment
performance or maybe this is your your
local host provider and you're going to
use that one unless it starts to run out
of power in which case you switch and
start using this post provider down here
and this can all be done automatically
without the consumer the consumer
doesn't know what's happening behind the
scenes or even these web service
providers themselves knowing what's
going on provided the broker can do that
so we started to look it broke as this
is the next big push that we have trying
to find ways so that host providers can
describe their current behavior the
price performance dependability
characteristics and so on and web
service providers can pass with the
messages the sort messages intended for
the service information what the quality
of service requirements are and then a
match can take place so yeah so go about
the previous example and this host
provider here maybe the local campus
grid and messages are routed to it and
this one down here is the National Grid
service which maybe it costs you
something in tokens to use that and so
you don't want to use it all the time
forgot local resources but if you really
need to get a job done and there aren't
local resources and you'll be prepared
to have your msgs process down there so
the last news case I'll company so this
is back to the original motivation that
I talked about so the question was
you've got some rewriting analysis
service it requires a lot of debt from a
day at best you can't afford to transfer
that over long distances because the
cost of moving the data kills the
overall performance so with with this
system then what we do is when we deploy
a database so just providing a database
server we also provide local compute
power set of nodes typically this is one
cluster we put the database service on
on some of the nodes and we probably we
put the host provider of the with the
resources to install and process
messages to services on the other nodes
and we just set up the web service
provider here for this particular
service so that it passes the messages
on here so automatically any services
here which are intended to process
things against this debt of ourselves
will be dynamically deployed close close
to it yes yeah so I have a side and
security a couple of slides on so I'll
cover that because it's an important
point okay and I think the next slide
gives you the yeah so hopefully you can
see this so this is the performances of
so this purple language was the one on
the previous slide and you can see when
we switch on dinosaur then and dynamic
service deployment then for the initial
message the cost before falls down here
so this includes the cost of deploying
the service once it's deployed
subsequent messages have a lower cost so
this the difference between here and
here is the cost of deploying the
service once you get down to once you've
deployed it once you don't have to
deploy again and so all you're doing is
routing messages are being processed by
those notes so you can see we wait for a
real example we get a significant
performance improvement by allowing the
services to be dynamically employed
close to the death okay securely so so
what do you do about security well we
we've been exploring what we call a
tripartite security model because
there's really three actors in this as
the consumer that sending the message to
the web service provider the web service
variety which is using a host provider
to install the services that a Downes
and process messages against them and
the sort of questions that we want it to
be able to allow the each of these
actors to to ask sort of these are
security assertions that we want it to
be able to to meet security requirements
so for it for a horse provider it may
want to accept only messages from
trusted web service providers so it made
it may trust them because they don't
send malicious code or maybe because
it's
a business relationship with him so
doesn't want any script kiddie to be
able to send services to it similarly
the web service provider may only want
its services to be deployed on horse
provider where trusts them not to say
resale well services independently or
too often you give them away without
payment and of course the consumer might
worry about so pharmaceutical companies
worry about where the messages go to
they don't want people looking at their
sort messages and discovering which
particular drugs error which particular
genes are investigating at the moment
where the drug targets are so the
consumer may want to have a say in the
host provider that's used so we we have
this way of expressing these assertions
in excess ml and then this is enforced
at runtime so as the messages go through
the system they're signed by the
participants and then these the security
assertions are checked so that the each
party can hopefully be be comfortable
with the decisions that are there so
ensure access resources are there have
been somehow delegated from the client
or were impersonating the clients are
they taking down get access to certain
resources that only the client in in
heaven so so so so what would happen
would be the client let's say the client
specifies that it only trusts a host
provider that's running on IBM Microsoft
HP sir 33 companies and trusts so it
sends it makes that assertion in the
message which goes to the web service
provided the web service provider also
may only trust some subset of those that
merely trust lets it trust Microsoft and
IBM so that limits the choice by the
time it gets to a host variety which
must then be Microsoft and IBM then that
horse provider can check who the
consumers in the web service provider is
and make sure it's happy with with with
those two and if I if that's the case
then it will process the message of the
wiser it'll just reject it
for example access terror server and in
order to dance his Terrace every half
day you know he has he has to be the
client you know because only the client
has an account on terror server so how
does the host provider say okay not when
access to tears over taxes the data
because I was told to do that but you
know I don't really have an account with
terror server only the client does so so
it sort of them proxy delegation type
yeah
yeah okay so I suppose that I suppose we
assume that it's the host provider that
has the as the ownership of the
resources and that it has to be happy
with a particular consumer rather than
two to use those resources as if it was
that consumer I think what you're saying
is the house the buyer is extra tied to
some set of resources like Tara server
for example yes educated through some
important through the web services the
hell of the problem and he talks to the
most provided other provider says okay
well I've been are you don't even the
client to give that client joy been
authenticated by the web services and
therefore and I have access to this
server yeah where I can access all the
data lon yes yes I think that's the
model that we have at the moment whether
whether we could try whether it be
there's a richer model in there that we
could try to implement where the host
provider between a hug provider and just
just particular resources so yes your
words are very complex you know service
you know the host provider might not
have access all we read all the types of
resources then the client wants access
what you but okay yeah so so I guess
that's true so the you rely on the host
provide to be able to process the
message do everything that you're part
of that if it has to do anything else
then that would have to be partitioned
as another service which would then go
through this this process again I don't
think I need to dwell on the
implementation it's probably just what
you'd what you'd expect the one point I
wanted to to make was that we don't we
don't want this too we're not proposing
this to replace existing grid fabrics of
grid fabrics do good things they tell
you where resources are what software is
deployed on them and give you a way to
route messages to those resources so and
that's what we need so we're building on
top of this at the moment we do it in an
ad hope I'd help where we've got our own
host provider interface layer and we run
our own infrastructure rock on door at
the moment but what we're doing is that
this is so another thing but Tony here
did before he came here was he set up
this open middleware infrastructure
Institute which provides useful services
and supports useful services free
science and one of them is a general
interface to two grid fabrics which is
this grid Sun service so we're
reengineering what we do to sit on top
of that then whatever the underlying
grid fabric is the idea is that we can
then talk to through this in this
particular service so we're not tight
one infrastructure and you end up with a
system something like like this one here
so this is this is this is what we see
as being the way in which these dynamic
service grids would would work so you've
got the host providers with the
resources web service providers with
service repositories and the brokers who
are making the decisions about where to
route messages so these are the main
components we see and we think the key
to success is content rather than
infrastructure so we think that if
people produce services and package them
in this way that can be dynamically
deployed then this whole approach could
take off but I think it's a usual thing
that infrastructure on its own isn't
enough you need there in theater and
services in order to in order to attract
people to it and
but the other side what sort of
structure should people be deploying if
they've got some day they want to make
available so this is this is a we're
trying to think about a standard way to
now to make database information
available any science so rather than
people do it not hot ways for each
different projects so we got a date in
the metadata we usually find this effect
set of useful services so at the month
will work with neuroscientist and
there's some standard ways in which
people want to process information that
come off the arrays that they stick into
people's brains in order to get the
traces of what their what their brains
are doing with some standard analyses
which produce spikes which then go back
into me to this data stores but there's
also the again the clever scientists to
coming into work thinks of some new way
to analyze the data so we have these
fixed services that we offer boss we
have the resources to deploy services is
required using the dinosaur approach
work for enactment engine so this is the
sort of unit that we're now deploying
for e science okay so we've got will
experiment with bio informatics services
at the moment so we populate in these
libraries with with bio services we
started to do work in virtual machines
that I talked about which I see has been
the way of the future for this we're
looking at the brokers use of qos to
guide decisions about where to deploy
service and where to route messages
within the host provider we've got some
work on mathematical modeling and
building software based on those models
to decide when to deploy a service on a
new node because that can be a that can
have a high cost so one of the companies
we deal with is BTW and their customers
like the idea of being able to
dynamically deploy services software
infrastructure on a node but they want
it to be scrubbed before and after their
services being deployed on it they don't
trust the leakage of information in
these nodes that you know it's the order
of hundreds of seconds in order to
a in order to do this in it and there's
a result you have to think very
carefully before you consider deploying
a service on a no so there's models
which which treat that and reproducible
in inside to talk about the fact that
there's these concerns if debt as well
scientism reproducible well if the
services themselves are lost then we
lose the ability to reproduce what was
done we can't regenerate the result if
we have the services in libraries then
as we go and process dare to go through
a workflow which takes their or and
there's something to it stores the
result at the moment work on provenance
tends to store the data so you can we
have for example have a work for an
admin engine which automatically stores
who run the work floor when they run it
what the inputs were what the outputs
were what the services were were called
and we're starting to think that maybe
if you want full reduce reproducer built
as well as that you would also store a
version of the service and make sure
that there's a long-term archival
storage of that service so in 50 100
years time somebody could come back and
reproduce your your results in the same
way that people can look in journals and
see the the day which published in that
so again we feel that the virtual
machine approach is the only hope for
the long-term survival of services fine
you also reproducibility you you want to
have information about like the types of
machines you were running out as well
and reacts 86 machine yes yeah we're
having that discussion is yes yes have
lots of information about you know what
the environment was that you were
running this job in
can replay it somewhere I think it's a
top problem yeah like that's the same
problem that we have with software
development and archiving the tools and
everything else and over years of its
portability of those it's not be here
just to seeing what you could be mold
from those folks yes so so we we have
good links who commit the software
testing and now have very similar
problem as you say they set up these
these standard environments in a windows
95 windows 2000 windows XP and so and
then they won't have that environment
available any time to try and reproduce
faults and so on and so yes yes yes so
so get so so I think there are a lot of
links to the software to the software
development testing process as well as
what goes on inside okay so I think so
so I think done suggest about 50 minutes
I've got a lot of five minutes ago so
what I'll do is I'll just do this part
part very very briefly so localizing so
I've been describing how we think it's
important to localize computation or
dare but there comes a point where you
have to accept that you can't localize
everything and that's one of the big
lessons of V science that there's lots
of groups now publishing data and
scientists really get benefit by
combining this combining integrating
this information together and I wanted
to show you how this often happens at
the moment in these signs so you won't
be able to read this but this is a this
an example of a real work floaties done
by a researcher Newcastle aristocratic
and this is to do some analysis of a
disease called Graves disease so that
some information comes from an
experiment and there are lots of
services which are used to produce a set
of results which the biologists can then
look at and try to work out which genes
are doing are doing what and it's not
unusual for work flows of services to do
biological processing to be that
complicated in fact as an aside one of
the things that we discovered so as in
many parts of
computing people think well we'll just
get something to work and then we'll
make it reliable so people produced work
for enactment engines which could
process these sorts of work for us and
then they discovered that they could
never ever run run the work flow because
there's always one service down any time
they've tried to run it once you get
beyond about 20 services and so
immediately dependability had become a
priority and words of retrying having
alternative services that you could use
I starting to become important and but
if you look at what's going on there
then a lot of what people are doing is
to use workflows to combine information
from multiple information resources and
you get the same sorts of issues so you
get complexity you get bespoke
implementation of debt operations life
you look at what people are doing the
joining information they're doing unions
they're filtering it and floor control
becomes a problem as well because you've
got a huge amounts of data flowing
around these these workflows now these
issues have already been tackled in the
area of query processing distributed
query processing so we've been looking
at how to use a generic distributed
processing service to try to reduce the
complexity of workflow are the data
virtualization of harvest idea yes so in
order for our distributed query
processing system to work all of the
services have to have a standard
interface so there's a standard way to
get the schema so the physical matter
day the logical matter they rapin
there's a standard where to send them
queries we don't actually in this part
of talk we don't do this man again to go
inside which is another level of trying
to get homogeneity so the fact that in
one database what somebody calls the
temperature yeah if there's a table
another one where it's called temp and
you need to know that these two are
actually there this the same thing so we
don't actually tackle that way down
Italy the lower level plumbing
and so so we've got a distributed query
processing system which is had I think
700 downloads now and so it's quite well
used for you science and people can
write queries in standard query language
so this one is for to do some analysis
some genetic analysis fine proteins that
are similar to proteins that run at
eight with the gene ontology term 5942
so you can write that as a as a query
because we can include service calls
within these queries we can combine
computation debt so this is the standard
blast bioinformatics service call it
does gene sequence analysis and what we
do is we I'm going to skip this and show
you the various stages so we we take the
query and we compile it and we can do
this on multiple nodes so this is what
we end up with so we partition the the
query across a set of nodes so this part
here this is doing a scan of one of the
two databases which are being used here
and this could be moved to a node which
was close to that this similarly for
this one here and then there's a hash
join which combines the date between
them and then we do this blast corps and
because we're doing this utilizing
underlying grid middleware what we can
do is dynamically acquire resources in
which to do the different parts of the
query so for example the the hash join
the optimizers decided be good to have
five nodes to do it so these are the
nodes on which that would be Brunson
goes out in aqueous five nodes from a
pool of nodes managed by grid middleware
distributes the this part of the query
partition to them and organizes that the
debt is sent there is appropriate
similarly with this blast here because
this might have been a bottleneck then
this is distributed on the two nodes
where this is the blast services it's
running and again the result of another
long flight so this is what's happening
in reality on our system so we grabbed
five nodes for the debt at the protein
table generates tuples which is spread
out across to build hash tables on these
nodes and then the other table
soft start to sender the hashes are
performed the results go of these blasts
nodes where they're processed and
eventually the dirt that goes back to
the user so we feel the advantage of
this is if you can imagine if we didn't
have distributed query processing then
somebody would have to write a work
floor to do this they would have to go
out and somehow dynamically acquire a
set of nodes which is appropriate to
that workflow based on the amount of
data they would then have to do all of
the flow control so making sure that the
data is not just gigabyte of data
streamed up to these nodes here if they
can't cope with its or transferring
different tuples in blocks of tuples at
the right rate for them to be consumed
the thing we've started to look at next
is adaptivity so we've now got this to
be adaptive so if you're going to grab
nodes dynamically then you don't own
those notes and there's a real danger
that they'll be withdrawn or that they
might fail you're much you've got much
less tight management of them than if
you're in a traditional query processing
world where you're running it on your
own box that you manage and you
carefully carefully look after so one of
the things we've done for example is to
we can automatically from one of those
queries which are shown written a high
level query language we can add in the
in the infrastructure to make a tolerant
to node failure so the way in which we
do this is that as the operators flow up
here between these different nodes a
copy of the operators are kept so a copy
the tuples are kept down here and every
now and again there's a marker tuple
inserted into the flow of tuples when
that marker 20 gets up to here that
means all of the tuples that were here
have been processed through this note
here and have arrived here so a message
comes back saying throw those tuples
away we don't need them but if this node
fails then what we can do is to go and
grab another node to replace it
automatically and to ask this node here
to resend all of those tuples that are
buffered here to the new node so we can
continue without losing any data with
having to start the query again so we've
got long running queries this could be a
useful approach
and of course it all depends on the
performance that you get us a whether
it's useful giving some some results the
interesting ones are these ones up here
and here so this is for these results
here are 42 joins in a query and you can
see that we're varying here the block
length through this is how many nodes
you how many to twas you allowed to
proceed between these markers which are
going to use to control the the the
storage of copies of the vedetta and you
can see that if these are too small then
you end up spending too much of your
time sending these messages backwards
and forward seeing ok that the this set
of nodes has arrived at this at the
output of this join operator so you can
clear them out again but once you get to
300 I saw two balls before you insert
one of these markets then things settle
down you get quite a linear linear costs
or we'd probably suggest this is about
the right size for these these pork or
blocks if you're allow them to go too
big than the cost of recovery after
failure increases so the overhead well
see here the overhead so this is for to
join suits 600 seconds against 500
seconds or three joins 800 seconds
against 600 seconds so so there's an
overhead there it's it's quite big it's
not enormous and what we'd like people
to be able to do is just to decide when
they run the query how important it is
that they get the result back within a
particular length of time and if so
whether it's worth switching on this
automatically activity in the case of
failing ok so so to end so um so we
think in science is transforming
sciences more and more date have been
published but as usual it's there the
problem is not how much debt you have
but what you can actually do with it and
so you need these techniques to localize
computation today and also to integrate
distributed information their bases are
becoming important so they're starting
to be used more and more for debt or
rather than files which is a good thing
to have lots of good features including
the ability to localize computation in
terms of database research then there's
lots of interesting we feel
opportunities offered by grid computing
Andy science and things like the need to
adapt to failure or changes in changes
in the availability of nodes that you're
using to run your queries it raises some
interesting challenges things like
replication and caching so one of the
things you could do so dynamically
acquire nodes to use instead of Cash's
so for a set of queries it may be that
you can speed up a query by caching
temporary results and allowing those to
be reused close to worthy the results
are needed and many challenges ahead so
smartly integration was the one that to
try and get more homogeneity across
different databases that have different
learners have been set up with different
internal structures peer-to-peer we're
looking at peer-to-peer database system
so we have this this challenge could be
throw away their service and just use
peer-to-peer systems for doing
distributed query processing with the
data spread out across a set of peers
making use of all of the spare disk
capacity that there are on on people's
desktop PCs these days and the other big
change which is really going to affect
things are just starting is that more
and more scientific information is
coming through in sensors the ability to
process information coming in at a
constant rate in real time from sensors
and actually to extract value from it is
probably one of the main challenges that
we're going to have over the next few
years in managing there for me science
experiments and project
okay I have one question that you'll be
related to running these long running
very soon I is the user all involved in
understanding how long these queries are
running I mean do they really you know I
mean yeah this is literally do I know
but it's going or going to smoothie and
or something happen you know then there
any feedback in this loop at all so um
so the main street by the users get is
the response time that for their for the
query you know they see that how long it
takes now we've got a lot of detailed
performance analysis tools that we
ourselves use we've not really exposed
that to users at the moment I think that
yeah yeah it's still still going down to
don't don't give up on us yet we don't
actually have that at the moment but it
may well be a useful useful thing
particular very long running cruise with
the longest one that we've come across
at them so far is one that would take
about three months but but the person
who wants to do it hasn't been it
because of course is it there's a decent
chance that something will fail in that
three months and left to start again and
I'll never make progress so that was one
of the motivations but seeing whether we
could keep these long queries crews
running even given presence of one or
more node phillies in that time so yeah
I think that I think you're right so I
think that perhaps before people would
use these younger you really need to
give them much more much more meters and
information about what's going on in and
the the cost if they do decide to to
switch on the fault tolerant button you
know is it something decide whether it's
worth it or not
order a book from amazon and get
feedback until the book arrived in my
house as well as to whether or not that
that transaction was successful might
not go to that service yes yeah yeah
shows up in three days I not work I me
yeah and I guess I guess it with query
processing in general people just get a
feel for how long something text and
then you don't you don't usually get
feedback when you send a crew to
eventually get the results all commit
errors and failing yeah yeah so you know
that what you need to take appropriate
action yeah yeah yeah yeah it's good fun
from the site number but you had the
intersection between or something it's
kind you know exponential and whoa yeah
yeah yeah yeahs a sense of sort of like
what the actual distribution is on their
side made simply not if most of the
values that you actually observe our
right of that intersection it makes
sense to all your method but if yep
actually spending more time yeah no I
know I know what you mean so I think it
was that one that wasn't it yeah so to
the point you're making is that yeah so
so if you're going to be down here with
small values and it doesn't really
matter I mean I guess I guess you're
right so if you were if you're only
looking at that that one thing about
whether what we can do here is to is to
localize computation we've got lots of
lots of death being transferred and so
to stop you having this it's terrible
overhead up here that would be true i
think i think what we're what we're
hoping is that some of the other
benefits would still make it worthwhile
you know the benefit that is just the
library of services which dynamically
get deployed is required that would so
that you would still get get other
benefits rather than just to perform
it really is a you know it's cool it's
really quite difficult to to deal with
services and they thought environments
because you tend to go to a very manual
sort of service deployment environment
and just removing that we think could
could really make it much easier for
people to use these services just share
them oops do some research will put
years of work into a service and then
only there will be able to to get the
benefit from that so the idea here is
that then if we could just put into a
format was in one of these libraries
perhaps by sorting it out in a virtual
machine and then freezing it and putting
this possibly then lots of other lots of
other groups could gain the benefit here
grace nexus where microsoft and i don't
really work with scientist on every day
you know physical scientists so i don't
really get a sense for how much work is
being done these days in the lab and how
much is not the work of science talking
done on computers yes I'm reading is
like you know his time goes unless
unless time is getting spent in the lab
and just so much more time to getting
spent without trying to use you know
computers and that's why we're building
these that seems to be the trend I mean
in some ways I worry about making
generalizations because we probably
thought that people who are amenable to
using computers and the people who just
like to you know deal with test tubes
and do things on the backs of envelopes
then they probably don't talk to us but
I think one of the great so you think
about the drivers in this is probably
it's probably two or three so so one is
the fact that more and more of the
actual the wet experiments have been
done by machines now rather than by
humans so you get these big these these
are real machines which do lots of
analyses of the same sound hope to see
which genes are being expressed and
generating huge amounts of information
so getting to the point where human
couldn't really
do that anywhere and the advantage to an
organization of having some automated
where some work for which kicks in when
the dirt comes off the machine and did
some analysis or are really huge I think
I think the other the other reason in
large parts of biologists is that
biologists have been good at clearing
information so they have people who work
with archivists they take raw data and
there they the annotated they look for
debt which seems wrong in the thing
careful about whether that should go
into the record and then they store it
and then there are organizations that
then make that available through web
pages or services so that so over time
biologists putting more and more effort
into that aspect of their of their work
and that really increases the
opportunities for further IT this
ecosystem that I talked about services
that sit on top of services and so on I
think I think the other thing that we've
noticed is that a lot of the early use
of of computers in biology with with
through web pages and so the thought was
that people would sit there and it would
pay some guarantor web page and get some
interesting results back and over time
it became the integration of sets of
these processes together so got what you
got one web service put your day and you
get a result your screen scrape it into
another one and so on so so biologists
really top-flight biologist we're
spending our screen scraping from one
website to another manually and so if
you can show them that you can automate
this release of web services and through
the use of choreography systems like
like workflows then they can see the
positive benefit that they could then go
and spend more time on the science
rather than just that doing cut
so it's it's I think it's a set of set
of things the other the other the other
pressure from a different direction
comes from talking to pharmaceutical
organizations so they'd like to know
what on earth that people are doing you
know you know they've got lots of
scientists what are they doing and so
the idea of using these sorts of
techniques to finalize very attractive
so for example they can have
repositories of workflows and get
experts right workflows and then they
can monitor who's using which workflows
they can run provenant systems only but
time anybody does a calls a service
there's a there's a record kept so they
build up this corporate library of
information about who's who's doing what
they can search it to find out has
anybody done this before mr. here it
turns out it was from a process where we
think there's a bug in this process
which results were generated as a result
of that can we or it might be redo those
so so from from that side this lee it's
not so much the pressure that the
scientists have Ritzer pressure of an
organization wanting to have some
corporate information about what's going
on and to be able to get value
okay well thank you very much pleasure
thanks for your questions of interest